there is a revolt going on within the
Republican Party against Donald Trump no
the party hasn't officially said we no
longer support the guy that we just
officially nominated at the Republican
National Convention two weeks ago that
hasn't happened but we have a growing
list of current and former Republican
elected officials that are saying no I
am NOT going to vote for Donald Trump
this now includes main Republican
senator Susan Collins she says she's not
going to support Donald Trump basically
three issues for Susan Collins that did
it for her number one the quote
denigrating comments that Donald Trump
made about Senator John McCain as well
as fox news host megyn kelly number two
senator collins is increasingly dismayed
by Donald Trump's quote constant stream
of cruel comments and is inability to
admit error or apologize and number
three she was especially disappointed
about Donald Trump's attacks being
directed at people who quote could not
respond on an equal footing either
because they do not share his power or
stature or because Professional
Responsibility precluded them from
engaging at such a level this also is a
reference to the entire controversy over
gold star apparent cause ircon of
talking about initially the controversy
starting over his son deceased US army
captain who my own khan we talked about
that extensively last week now it's not
just Susan Collins 50 of the country's
most senior republican national security
officials many of whom worked for george
w bush not exactly a kind of a
progressive Republican by any means have
signed a letter that says Donald Trump
lacks the character values and
experience to be President he would put
at risk our country's national security
and well-being and would be the most
reckless president in American history
sounds like what a Democrat would write
Louis but this is actually 50 national
security Republican officials who say
yeah this guy is a danger to me maybe
the most shocking thing is that the
character values of Mitt Romney and
George Bush are supported by all
these national security individuals
right but they are right how could you
possibly have someone like Donald Trump
with his finger on on the the nuke but
it's also important to mention that this
is not just a letter saying they won't
support Trump it is a letter saying they
are going to be or i'm sorry it's not a
Paul Ryan type statement saying we
aren't endorsing the candidate it is
more to saying we are not going to vote
for the guy and that's increasingly
become an area of division among some
Republicans and then lastly just to sort
of flesh this entire thing out former
Michigan Governor a Republican William
Milliken has now said he is going to be
not only not voting for Donald Trump
voting for Hillary Clinton there's this
really interesting situation where when
we say this every time the Hillary
haters say well David this has nothing
to do with Donald Trump this is because
Hillary Clinton is the safe neoliberal
Warhawk establishment corporatist so why
wouldn't Republicans vote for her I
don't really think that's the case by
and large I think this is mostly about
Trump in his policies it actually
doesn't matter we don't even really need
to argue because whether you think
Republicans are going to not vote Trump
and or vote for Hillary because Trump is
a disaster or because Hillary is sort of
neo conservative and a war hawk they're
saying this they're doing this is bad
for the Republican Party and that's what
I think the focus needs to be Louis yeah
you can say the Republicans are voting
for Hillary because she's actually
basically a moderate Republican or a
moderate Democrat or whatever it
actually doesn't matter when you have
this number of former and current
Republicans saying we're voting for the
Democrat over the Republican that is
chaos in the Republican Party and that's
what's going to impact the party well
beyond november eighth it will but many
of them are still saying we're not
voting for Trump while not saying we are
going to vote for Hillary instead and I
know like we discussed many of them are
up for reelection and you don't wanna
you don't want to drop that bomb the
national security officials the forward
former Republicans though they hire know
uh that they're not posturing here for
their personal real actions you have
crossed the line when as a current or
four
Republican you say I am publicly telling
you I'm voting for the Democrat aside
from whatever the specific policy issues
maybe to that individual you're doing
long-term damage to the Republican Party
and we'll continue talking about it